لقد كانت إشارة قوية من
يوم تاريخي عالٍ لملايين النساء
وعائلاتهن هنا في المملكة العربية السعودية ،
أخيرًا تم منح النساء الضوء الأخضر
للقيادة ، أنا سعيد جدًا
بإصدار هذا وأتطلع إلى قيادة
هذه الخطوة التي جاءت من قبل العائلة المالكة  مرسوم صادر عن الملك
سلمان ولكن هذا كان له بصمات
نجله ولي العهد ورؤيته
2030 في كل ذلك أن خطة محمد
بن سلمان مصممة لتقليل اعتماد المملكة
العربية السعودية على النفط وتخلق
وظائف غير نفطية وتعزيز النمو الاقتصادي
أعتقد أننا أدركنا ذلك  سوف يعيدك الانتقال
إلى الوراء قليلاً في البداية
، وكل ما أضافه لا ألم
ولا ربح يلعب دورًا كبيرًا في أي شخص
يعتقد أن هذا مجرد مفتاح
سيظهر وقد تم تضليله
وأعتقد أن الشعب السعودي جاهز
على المدى الطويل ، كان أكبر جهد لهم
جميعًا هو التعويم بنسبة 5 في المائة لشركة
النفط الحكومية العملاقة أرامكو السعودية التي
يقول مستشارو البنك إنها لا تزال على المسار الصحيح
للنصف الثاني من عام 2018
على الرغم من تذبذب السوق.  على العكس من
ذلك ، فإن الأهداف على المدى القريب حتى
عام 2020 هي التي قد تحتاج إلى تعديل 1.2
مليون وظيفة جديدة من القطاع الخاص في
الوقت الحالي ، حيث يبلغ متوسط معدل البطالة أقل من
0000 سنويًا خارج نطاق ال
طالة الحكومية المكونة من رقمين إل
9٪ أو  انخفاض النمو وإعادة إشعاله ،
فإن التوقعات تشير
إلى استقرار الاقتصاد في عام 2017.
رجال الأعمال العالميون وقادة الحكومات ،
وخاصة من الرئيس الأمريكي دونالد
ترامب ، في
الآونة الأخيرة ، قام الملك سلمان
بمحور رفيع المستوى لروسيا
للقاء الرئيس فلاديمير بوتين ،
ووقعوا سلسلة من الاتفاقيات المشتركة التي
ستساعد المملكة العربية السعودية في
الإصلاح الاقتصادي الذي يريد الكثيرون رؤيته.
نجح ولي العهد صاحب القيادة القوية والذي
بدوره يساعد على زيادة الطلب
على الشركات الأمريكية والروسية ولكن ينتقل من هنا
إلى النهاية  سيكون خط h بالفعل
مليئًا بالتحديات John Tefft arias CNNMoney
جدة المملكة العربية السعودية